Film Courage: What was your first professional
directing job? Ben Medina, Filmmaker: First
professional directing job was when I took a short
film I had directed when I was 22 (my first film
shot on film) and I had a choice to make between
take that film and try to raise money and try to
write a script and be an indie filmmaker or to go
into commercials and advertising. So I chose the
latter and I went into advertising like some of
my heroes Ridley Scott, Tony Scott, David Fincher.
I took that film into several ad agencies and was
offered a job right away and and then they said
we want you to shoot something on spec for us
because shooting your own film and shooting a
commercial is completely different when
it comes to parameters for time and
budget and so forth and i got offered a script for
a black and white surf style uh 16 millimeter um
surf like it was sort of like in the vein of the
malloy brothers jack johnson you know this sort
of like surf awesome guitar commercial for this
taco brand and um so i shot it on film shot on
black and white reversal which they didn't want me
to do i wanted to shoot on color and i wanted to
do change the color in the di and i insisted
on black and white reversal and we shot it
and the client loved it it was a look they
didn't anticipate had kind of a it had kind of a
an endless summer style to it but it was very very
very high contrast so it felt very portrait-esque
with these beautiful people eating burritos oh
wow that's awesome and they really dug it and uh
so i got known as the guy who is a little
analog you know that was like right when red
camera was taking off and i kept pushing analog
the whole time i kept wanting to shoot on film
um because we were gonna be seeing everything
in digital i wanted to go the other way so that
when you saw my work or the work of that agency
that it would pop you know come out of people
so yeah you said you were 22 22. yeah so this was
in the washington area yeah yeah i shopped my reel
which was a five-minute uh boxing prize
fighter um short film called in the corner
which no one will ever get to see uh i
shopped at around seattle and portland
and a couple of other small markets i knew that i
wanted to stay in the pacific northwest i didn't
want to go to la yet and so yeah i shopped
at i think three or four agencies and two of
them were really interested and then i went
with the one that had the biggest accounts
because i wanted to work on big commercials from
day one yeah 22. how does a 22 year old convince
an ad agency executive to use film and and
do it sort of more i i did a lot of homework
before my first meeting so those pitch meetings
uh which took some time to get i called around
and i figured out who the creative directors were
i looked at their work i looked at who was doing
stuff that was very trendy and and sort of just
what you would expect from an ad agency and then i
looked at cds work that it was really provocative
or old school or they were going for the kernel
of an idea that that maybe the audience or the
consumer wasn't expecting with some success and
some failure you know you look at ad campaigns
and you're like that was a great idea or that
was great execution and a terrible idea and um
so i was really looking for agencies that did
really interesting stuff and fortunately the the
creative director that i worked with um or create
chief creative officer because he was the honcho
he had a passion for film and he had a passion for
aero morris and he had a passion for scorsese
and he liked these eccentric pictures that
other people would never know and i knew what they
were and so when i sat down with this particular
individual and i showed him my film he said oh
you shot on 16. i said no i shot on super 16
and i started talking about film stocks and he
knew some of that but he didn't know all of it
but he was turned on because he was like this kid
which i was a kid um wants to be um he wants to
go after things like a filmmaker not like um not
like a copywriter or whatnot and um so we ended up
talking about films like the last waltz right
or um endless summer came up of course tokyo
olympiad which is a really awesome criterion
documentary about the tokyo olympics where they
i think it's like 10 or 12 filmmakers they hired
different filmmakers and each filmmaker shot
different events differently so some shot video
some shot eight mill some shot 35 millimeter
and then they cut it all together in a documentary
that that actually was primary topic of our first
interview we talked about this very obscure
documentary that only cinephiles really know
about and um and uh and then we ended up
nerding out on film stock and so he from
day one he was very um supportive of trying to
get that across the line um with all the clients
and some of them said no um so then he was really
supportive of if we weren't gonna shoot film and
we were going to go digital that we studied it
you know he gave me this bandwidth like time and
some resources to say hey we're not shooting film
what should we shoot on you know and uh it was um
you know the advertising industry paid for me to
go to film school do you remember how much you
were paid for this first directing gig yeah i had
a very interesting um role at that agency because
they didn't hire me freelance to direct they hired
me to direct a lot of their stuff so i kind of
had a contract right away which is very unusual
usually you're freelance director and you pick up
this and you pick up that and i think because of
this creative relationship that i had right away
with this creative executive that he really wanted
that he wanted like oh hey if you're going to
direct or dp what we're doing i want you to do
all of our stuff so all of our stuff has a brand
right because one of the ways things become really
inefficient in commercial production until you get
to a certain level when you're paying for a name
or you're paying for an established director that
has a brand that brings gravitas to a project but
everything else is has an inefficiency to the fact
that you know you build the whole production
team and then the next project you change it
all again and the next project you change it all
again um and that can be beneficial for multiple
clients of course but this particular agency's
size had some big accounts but not a lot and so
they uh they thought it was really beneficial
to hire me and put me on salary so and i think
i made 42 000 a year and then within about a year
i sat them down and asked for a massive race so
how long did you end up staying with this just
under three years yeah yeah it was very uh
i came right in at the time when they had an nfl
team account and i got to work on that account
at a high level and that that team went to the
super bowl and our work was up on jumbotrons and
they were using our work to do big advice and
so it was kind of like it was kind of like being
on top of the wave before it rises you know so it
was a timing thing um but but getting in that door
was about a a collaborative passion for film and
movies and talking um uh talking at length i mean
we would go on location in new york or montreal
and we'd be in the car for hours this uh creative
director and i or we'd be on flights and we would
just start talking about movies and so we had this
we were both always kind of in agreement secretly
that every commercial could be a film and
that stuck with me that sort of rebellion you
know because the client wants you to photograph
their chicken or their burrito or something and
we wanted to tell a story about why people even
care about this brand and um that that stayed with
me through all of my advertising career because
i always was pushing back on aesthetics like
what it should look like or on the fact that
it needs to have a story or people don't care and
sometimes when you're in a room full of marketing
people they really don't care about your point of
view about that so um so yeah i stayed there for
um a few years and then i moved on is there
a style to finesse that especially because
you might have been one of the youngest people in
the room i'm just assuming i was for a while yeah
i was usually the youngest which
means i tried not to say much
unless i felt really i really wanted to listen
i really wanted to learn i didn't know the
advertising world at all you know and i didn't
presume to know how a client gives an agency a
million dollars to shoot an ad campaign like i'm
like i don't know how that happens and how do they
siphon off a half a million of that to do a tv
spot campaign right or whatever the budget is so
it was a lot of shutting up paying
attention um and so the finesse or the
negotiation between an agency and a client is
each one of those relationships is very unique
right because you have some clients who will talk
to the creative team at an agency and they'll say
we trust you go for it right that's the optimal
situation and then you'll have a pessimistic
situation which is a client that's like we
need close-ups of the mop or the chicken or the
sport cleat or whatever it is and you'll say
well who's you know who's holding the burrito
where are they and how did they get there and
why are they there and that's the story of that
ad right and there are some clients that are um
not interested not interested they're interested
in thinking that the reason why people buy
things is because they're robots and they're not
people buy things because they decided to accept
your invitation so and i think advertising
is an invitation you can make an invitation
for people and a lot of people um i mean
advertising shifted a lot since i was 22. um
and it's very there's a lot of things overall
in the market that are way more beautiful
or the production value of things is better
but the storytelling is the same it's still very
a to z on one side you have absolutely excellent
storytelling that happens to be about a brand
right and then on the other end you have like
um you know a detergent ad that's just telling
you how clean your socks are gonna be so yeah i
don't know much about the nuance of actually
convincing someone to want to shoot my idea
like i actually don't know how to do it exactly i
think what i learned over time was you get to know
the client really well and you work on their trust
and they'll trust you more and more and then if
something's not successful you'll figure that
out and they'll say hey your big idea didn't work
and i've had really big advertising ideas that
didn't work and i've had really big advertising
ideas that um that no one believed in but me and
some other people and it got shot and it got done
in one awards and whatever and um so i always paid
really close attention to the trust level between
the agency and the client and how to you know
when the trust is right you go okay cool then
we can do this did you think about if you hadn't
done your research and gone for that interview
where your career would be no never because
that's just how i am you know um when i was
14 i thought i wanted to be a fashion
photographer so i shot a lot of photography
and developed my own film and learned how to
use a lot of different kinds of cameras and
work in the dark room and there was a photographer
in the town that i lived in and grew up in that
was really well known very very highly known
guy and his name is paul boyer and he did a book
called 100 over 100 where he went around the
world and met with a hundred people who were
over 100 and photographed them in these beautiful
portraits and did a book and it's incredible book
and it had just come out you know right about
that time when i was about 13 or 14. and i did
a lot of research on him and ended up knocking
on the door of his studio and after a few um
knocks uh i met with him and you know i
just wanted to talk to him for like you
know and he said okay you can talk to me for
a half hour and i remember it very very well
my i couldn't drive my mother took me to this
guy's like huge photo studio on the corner of
a city block and that was massive and um
she says okay i'll be out in a half hour
and i would start i talked to him for like three
hours you know and so the research thing started
then which was like if i really cared about
something i wanted to learn about it and also
accept the humility of like this
is my this is my knowledge line
this is where it is so the next person i'm
gonna learn from has to be great right and um
so that three-hour conversation turned into
me working for him for three years yeah and
i went to italy with him to do a book and um he
taught me everything i ever could imagine about
every format of photography and i was very patient
and he was very like um uh he had daughters he
didn't have a son so we had a very we had a very
like we weren't father and son at all but we were
we really cared about each other and he took
me under his wing in a way that wasn't like a
regular like assistant he was like it reminds me
of like the way a painter would have an apprentice
in like renaissance you know florence where they
say hey you earned this spot now i'm going to um
teach you everything i know but i'm going to hold
you accountable to the knowledge and he would he
he for example he wouldn't let me shoot a single
frame of medium format film for like a year uh
he would let me load his hasselblads he taught me
how to do it basically blindfolded like and but he
said you know you have to earn every shot you have
to earn every frame and every frame matters and um
so that taught me a lot i felt i felt this
sense of reward that i had studied him and
then when i met him i had enough information to
sort of represent myself you know be like i'm
serious man i'm [ __ ] serious about this and
i'm 14. and uh he took a sh took a shot on me
you know with with me working with him and
changed my life forever uh but it also taught me
that that research is necessary if you want to
do anything else and uh so i don't think about
if i wouldn't have studied the people i wanted
to present my short film to because that was just
the way i was and the way i am now you know i read
about you guys before i got here right all lies
um so yeah no i don't really think about that
but anyway it's a good question it's a great
question well thank you yeah it's a time machine
question right what the you know what if i'm just
glad i'm not a lawyer did you that was actually
my next question so not were you planning to
go to law school but you knew you loved the
image still image moving image whatever yeah
did you it seems like you kind of have always
known what you've wanted to do since you were
a young age um i think that you mean to be a
director film director or something in terms
of you want to be behind a camera yeah creating
something uh i did i i did i was very resolute
like you know uh until i was in my sort of like
mid-teens or whatever you know and i i was on
a mock trial team which is like a fake legal team
and you study a brief and you study a case and all
this and i was really passionate about the law
and when i went to university i studied acting
and i focused on japanese acting and some russian
acting stanislavski technique but then i also
studied international law and i kind of had for
probably about i don't know five or five five
years six years i had sort of two mistresses do
you know what i mean i was like i really love
film and i love photography but it
hadn't yet really turned into directing
right it was a it was being a photographer right
and i looked at the landscape of how you become a
photographer and i looked at the landscape of
of what really turned me on and there was this
combination that started to evolve which was
photography and acting okay great that's that's
film right and then i started writing in my late
teens um you know sketches short films and then
when i was in acting school it started to evolve
that there's an aspect of the theater that i
after having done a lot of theater and
being super passionate about shakespeare and
all that i actually had an experience on stage
once where i became very detached from being
on stage i was like i don't want to do this
anymore and um and about three months later
i i began planning that first short film that
boxing movie because i said this passion for the
theater that's been there since i was 15. it six
years later five six years later is starting to
crumble so is it crumbling because it's dying
and it needs to die and sometimes passions
need to die or is it transforming to something
else and it was definitely transforming into
oh i want to be able to control this actor
or that actor or this part of the scene
and theater's alive so it's not that so film is
that motion is that making movies is controlling
every aspect you can and then building it and
cutting it and building a rhythm and editorial
where it's alive right but it's it's like
filmmaking is the greatest illusion ever
and it's the best of all art forms in my opinion
because it's a convergence of all of them so um so
it was very odd because i shot a couple of shorts
in high school that were basically like my way of
talking out talking my way out of a test you know
the teacher's like we're going to do a test on the
20s and i said i'll make a short film about a
speakeasy during prohibition and she's like i
don't know how you're going to get into a bar but
okay and i did and we shot it and it was very like
again no one will ever ever see that um but so
it was interesting it was like it was it was not
spielberg oriented or um some other directors
who like you know like jj abrams who like shot
super eight film when he was like eight and
he's always gonna be a director it was a more
um it was much more of a journey where
i think it's like when you're climbing
a mountain or you know or you're in a
sailboat or something like that and you
say i'm going to go there i'm definitely
going there and as you get closer you look
beyond where you thought you were
going to go and you sort of trust um
your own judgment and the universe and then you
really take advantage of opportunity you know
when someone presents an opportunity you go yeah
i want to do that and i would never have thought
i would never have thought at the
end of university that i would have
been a commercial director like six months later
like never but then it happened and then it was
like yes this is so this is magical this is it
you know and um so i wouldn't presume to say that
i always had this master plan because i didn't
and um i trusted where things were taking me
and then when it clicked though oh that was
amazing you know when i shot that first um when
i shot that first short film i remember um we were
shooting a fight sequence overcranked um on 16 mil
i had all these actors i had gone to acting school
with who were working for sandwiches right and you
know we had like one overhead like kino and um i
remember shooting these first few reels of film
and then we took them to the lab and then we got
them back and i i um i remember this uh sense of
um watching uh like uh in the film the prestige
he talks about that there's three parts of a magic
trick and the third part is called the prestige
it's when you they blow your mind right and i
remember having that feeling of this is this is it
this is all those things that have come together
uh this is acting this is writing this is
photography and also from having traveled
having had the opportunity to travel a lot
when i was younger and and go to galleries
and see paintings of beautiful work that some
were singed into my memory it was this um
catharsis birth you know chrysalis whatever
you want to call it it was just this moment of
absolute connection and everything made sense
um and that began a very hard road to now
your love for justice your love for the law
i still love it i still love it a lot i read
a lot about international law i wanted to when i
was studying i wanted to i was very interested in
that there's this assumption when you grow up
in america if you have certain opportunities
which i did and you grow up in a certain sort
of like socio-economic demographic and whatnot
where you go oh you know every other nation in the
world has our kind of law enforcement and our kind
of democracy and which is super naive and not true
and as all of that becomes very clear there's this
huge canyon between our legal system which
is broken and it's working the best it can
and a country that has no legal system zero and
it's just free-for-all and it's pure crime or we
would define it as that with our legal system and
so i was always interested in right and wrong i
was interested in what people are capable of i was
interested in big cases like murder capital murder
i wasn't interested in why someone steals a car
i was interested in psychology of the law and i
was interested in the the presumption of innocence
which isn't true you know we say you're presumed
innocent until proven guilty and that's not true
um especially it's not true if you're not rich and
so what turned me on the most was uh international
law because that's where the most work needs to be
done as far as people being accountable for crimes
i studied a lot of war crimes but i also realized
something that um in my like fixation on the legal
process i was very interested in juries i was very
interested in um how an attorney communicates
with people who don't know anything about a case
which is storytelling and i remember having a
really interesting conversation with a judge once
a powerful guy in washington state and we were
talking about my future and uh i said i think i
was a junior in college and uh said hey you know
i think i'm gonna take lsats and i'm gonna give
this go and he talked me out of it and yeah he
was like he said i don't think that you actually
love the law and i don't think you actually
want to be an attorney and this is a guy who was
mentored since i was like 16 or something in high
school so you know five years or whatever it was
and he said no i don't think he should do it
and i said why not he said i think you like i
think you like telling the jury the story of the
crime i think you like standing up there and um
you know being um the you know tom cruise and a
few good man right or atticus or um or the firm
or the firm uh or mcconaughey hand a time
to kill or or you know what not and um
those crime are sorry those those trial dramas
that were great films uh with great performances
because he saw me in a courtroom doing mock trial
and he said i think that you like performing
more than you really like sitting down and
reading a book of jurisprudence and looking at
um looking at case law i don't think you're
passionate about that and he said if you're
a really great attorney you have to be
passionate about that there's a history
side to the legal system that you have to
be really um interested in and i i i told
him the truth i was like i'm not interested
in that i'm interested in convincing these
convincing these people that this person is guilty
or not guilty or whatever and um he said well
you're proving my point and you you shouldn't
do this then because that's not ethical because
that's not a good enough reason to go through
law school or to go through whatever the um
you know whatever the you know whether it's public
practice or whether it's private practice you know
you're either going to be working for a gigantic
firm and toe on the line or you're going to be
learning about the politics
of the inner workings of a
of a da's office or something and he's like
you know when it's dark and the demons come
you have to be passionate about the law and you're
not you're passionate about telling the story and
so that sent my that sent my pursuit of
justice into a tailspin because i felt
like i felt like i hadn't been telling myself
the truth about why i had been pursuing that um
and then i was in a couple of plays that dealt
with the law and it kind of solidified it it was
like oh man this guy's super right i like telling
this story i don't you know i don't care about
this actual trial i care about the experience for
the audience and so so yeah so by the time i um
decided to make a short film my flame for
being an attorney had gone out what about
uh doing a documentary on a case um i have i
don't have a strong affinity for documentaries
i've watched a number of them i've watched
a number of documentaries most documentaries
that i've seen have been recommended to me to
see i don't go out i don't go documentary film
festivals i don't i don't search through you know
documentary lists and look for docs um there's
something about that that's super true and real
and beautiful and human that's not manipulated
i mean some documentaries are manipulated but or
they have a voice they're trying to have a voice
that is trying to stay as true in the wind
as possible um but i far prefer the beauty of
and the creation of something original and
telling a story that hasn't been told before
if you watch a documentary you know the end like
mostly mostly like oh it's about this and that's
what that's about and that's what happened
right like if a documentary was about kennedy
assassination you're like i wonder what that's
about right as opposed to sitting down in the dark
with a film maybe you've only seen a trailer for
or maybe you've only seen a press junket thing for
and time traveling you know you sit in
a dark room and everything goes dark
and you go somewhere else you know
one of the one of the earliest films
that i um that stayed like in my heart and my soul
until today um and will continue to is the film
ask the mohicans and i saw that film my dad we
went twice and that's truly time travel like you
go into that film um and you know i think i saw
that in 93 or something so i was young and right
away michael mann puts on screen i think it says
1777 or 1778 and it has this you know beautiful
gorgeous score and then it starts in the blue
mountains and you're like i am there um and i'm
super passionate about telling a story that's not
true and a documentary is generally true and um
i am really passionate about creating an illusion
you know of of um of something from nothing and uh
so yeah that's why i didn't make a documentary
about the law but there's some really awesome ones
that i like a lot but i have friends who are like
super keen on docs and i kind of i kind of rely
on them i'll be like hey man what's super good
and then they tell me what to watch um but i i
would prefer to watch something else that is going
to take me into a world i've never been to before
how does an american director end up in new
zealand i was the creative director for tequila
brand um in my mid to late 20s and i had been
working with the team that designed the bottle
and designed the logo and the branding and
the identity and had done beautiful work just
just extraordinary work and this was a design
agency in new zealand i became very close with
a guy named dave quinlan and we became buddies
he became like my kiwi friend we would skype
and you know we would talk in meetings between
agencies but then we would like see how each
other's families are doing and so forth and i
had made i left that agency and his design firm
still had the account and i came to la and i was
working in la and i was shooting commercials in la
i was i was writing a lot here and um i wasn't
feeling the town the town's vibe was not my jam
and it was like um uh i think it was kind of like
it was not anything harsh you know people have
said really harsh things about la or not digging
it but like for me it was sort of i went to
a restaurant or i went to a film or i went to
a concert and in my mind i was going to go to
this one kind of restaurant or this one kind of
concert it was one kind of film and then when i
got to la the experience was different it was
i'm not talking about restaurants i'm talking
about metaphors where it's like i heard like it
was not the same vibe i thought it was gonna be
it just wasn't it just wasn't clicking it you
know i met some great people here i still have
those friends are still friends today um but
the town itself the the energy of the town
without it being woo sounding woo-woo it's
like it just wasn't like filling my soul
and i also came from like i've talked about
with photographer advertising agency etc
i had come from an environment where i had
reached out to mentors i had reached out
to people way better at what i wanted to
do than than i was at the stage i was at
and i didn't find any of that in la i found a
sense of i found a sense of unimportance i found a
sense of i'm one of a million who wants to fulfill
a dream and it was never it's not a dream people
say that to me oh you fulfilled your dream and
i'm like it's just work this is building the next
you know bigger project it's not like i'm sitting
around rubbing a lamp right and waiting for a
dream to come true so when i was in la i expressed
that to my friends in new zealand and i said man
this town is not my jam you know it's not and and
i was working with some really creative people
doing some great work but you know there's a when
you make films or commercials like it's family
it's really a tight group of people and
i just wasn't finding my rhythm like they
had found their rhythm right they had found the
neighborhood they wanted to live in they had found
the place they were going to send
their kids to school they had found
their roots um i didn't find that in los angeles
when i came here and lived here and worked here
i was fortunate to work here i know a lot
of people who come here and nothing happens
so that was wonderful but my connection with new
zealand stayed true and robust and so that firm
invited me down to work on the tequila account
and to just sort of hang out in new zealand and i
i shot uh i shot a couple of projects
that were right up until i was gonna
fly out i remember leaving the set over in the
mountains i was on the set in the mountains at
this waterfall and i left got in my car and
drove to lax and flew to new zealand and uh
uh which is a very la moment you know i just
got offsetting a plane um and got off the plane
and fell in love with the landscape driving
from auckland airport into auckland city
went into the city it felt it felt a little bit
parallel to the waterfront of seattle which was
home it felt it was so clean and beautiful um and
i i went in may which is essentially their fall
you know um sort of their like october
november weather um and i stayed there
for three weeks and by the end of three weeks
we went from all sort of hanging out as buddies
to we had a business plan a business model an
agency we were going to run and a name and all
that and i left and came back here and sort of
put some of the stuff i was doing here on hold
and then for about a year i started going doing
i started commuting from new zealand to us to
from new zealand to los angeles so i would
go down to new zealand for like eight weeks
eight or ten weeks and then i would come back to
los angeles we were shooting work in la we were
shooting work in austin um a little bit in new
york and we had clients all over the place and
that opportunity in new zealand started to gain
momentum with the fact that um the relationships
that i couldn't really build very tightly in
los angeles just due to not having the vibe
i started to build in new zealand you know
like i built a really great relationship
with the camera house there i built a really
great relationship with a series of producers
some of the production companies there are far
more accessible than they are in los angeles
you know like to talk to a studio head here you
gotta like kill six people and you still might not
get a meeting um i'm joking about that uh but
in new zealand you like send the guy an email
or the gal an email and you say i'm this
person this is my work i'd like to meet uh
and they would be like alright cool because it's
a smaller community and they're not used to people
only coming and asking for things they're used
to people coming and saying oh yeah mate let's go
go to the pub and get a beer so i started
to really understand the film industry
from i met with people at village
roadshow i met with people at wetta i
i sort of really understand the film industry
not from a hollywood perspective but from that
perspective which is the same because they made
the same product that was going into hollywood
and being sold they had deals with studios
right and uh universal is big down there and so
so new zealand turned into a big robust
advertising factory of creative as well
so as the chief creative officer of that agency
i wrote and directed every commercial we did
so it was it was again this um it was
a craftsman opportunity more than i
didn't want to just leave la that wasn't the
point the point was i'm going to go and shoot
a ton of ads i'm going to work a lot and
i'm going to develop my craft more and also
i wrote five feature scripts
when i was there in about
uh in just under three years you know so it
was an opportunity to just like get in the
zone so yeah that's how an american
ended up in new zealand and it was
it was extraordinary it changed my life
forever having been in advertising having
been around the marketing world working
for this tequila company sure been in la
traveled do you think a filmmaker should have
their own marketing plan like their own brand
not just for their films but for them 100 100
um filmmakers need to think about marketing
they need to think about the brand
of their product they need to think
about who's going to buy their product who's
going to watch their movie now there's this
relationship that you have to build and it doesn't
come right away because if you've never marketed
anything before it's like two different parts of
your brain right you have to look at it like why
would someone choose to watch my film just swiping
through itunes or or even at a marquee in a cinema
why are they gonna watch your film it's very
hard to answer that question for for yourself
if you have no practice marketing anything because
you're going to be very subjective about your work
it's art it's precious it's yours there's a
there's a possession and a permission to it
that you know people um at different experience
levels they have different levels of control
over the way they hold what they make and it's
very difficult to step outside that ownership
of your work and look at it objectively and be
like does someone even want to watch this right
and so i think if filmmakers expose themselves
to marketing plans and marketing objectives it's
not about that they're gonna become a marketing
executive right and they're suddenly gonna um
they're suddenly gonna become jaded and they're
not gonna care about the passion of filmmaking
um and that's probably the worry they're like
i don't wanna study marketing because it'll
take away all of the magic right but then
you're also super naive about the fact that
you're not preparing yourself for success
because if you work super hard and you stay
really incubated and you know nothing about who's
going to participate with your brand or your film
you will probably only get to make one because it
won't be successful you won't have resources or
if you have investors they'll feel like nobody
saw the film it'll lose money so it's kind of uh
there needs to be a relationship
where you become familiar with
the dance between i have to look
objectively at the work because i am
making it for an audience which leads
me to my next point i guess which is
eventually you have to acknowledge an audience
and i know people who don't i know people who
are artists visual artists true and true i know
people who are screenwriters who don't care about
getting coverage or they don't care about
letting somebody else read their material
who may be objective or who may be critical and
that's great that's a hobby that's a hobby that's
not a professional a professional understands
the industry a professional understands that
it's a marketplace someone wants what you made
or they don't and if you want to have a career i
suggest that if people are really unfamiliar with
branding and marketing they try to understand it
at least that doesn't mean they need to have a
relationship doesn't mean they need to go shoot
ads but if they don't understand it then they are
um cheating themselves out of the possibility of
doing more work and so i think it's super critical
um i guess the other thing i'd say is that
one of the things that's happened for
me transitioning from advertising to
uh features was that relationship with
an audience you know i had opportunities
for lack of a better i had opportunities for lack
of a better phrase where i could get away with it
i could get away with pitching to a client
a highly artistic vision for a commercial
and they loved the idea so much that whether it
sold a lot more watches or athletic jackets or
motorcycles they loved the idea so much that i
wasn't accountable to an audience now that's a
huge privilege it's a really great opportunity
but i didn't really know that until i started to
go into developing the marketing plan and the
release plan for our feature because i was like
wait a minute what's my relationship with this
audience do i care about my audience or not
and do i even have one um i don't presume that
anyone looks me up or cares about me and maybe
that'll change someday but that's not why i
do what i do but i care about them i was at
i was at a premiere last week doing a q a and
the first thing i did before i said anything or
answered any questions the person was very
feverish they really wanted to ask a lot
of questions and it was and it was cool they were
awesome but before i did that i thanked everybody
i said uh i said you don't have cinema without an
audience you can have a film without an audience
because you made a film and it's just there but
if you try to show it in the theater and no one
goes it's not cinema because no one saw it and so
when i said that out loud it was sort of like a it
was like the finishing of an arc of an idea where
i was like wow people paid money to see my film
and that doesn't make me feel good
from an egotistical point of view
i mean it doesn't make me feel bad
but it makes me feel like the idea
that i wanted to understand why they would want
to see it felt complete and in that moment very
very personally in that moment all i wanted to
do was make my next film and finish it because i
wanted more audience members to see the next piece
of work and so i think there's a relationship
between marketing and branding and understanding
that you have to have an audience for it to be
a high-level piece of work and and i hope people
can figure out their own relationship with
making art and marketing their art and
generally speaking it's a tough ask so i
would just say people should open their minds
and you did a short film about is it an art
thief so what happened with that was uh i wrote
my friend and i wrote a feature about
a heist an art heist that's real and
we wrote it and we shopped it to two people and i
hadn't i hadn't directed a feature yet so it was
they said basically you can
do two things with this script
you can sell it on spec and that was
on a table you know it has a um it has
a ocean's 11 tone to it um but it's a little
bit darker than that it's kind of like um
american animals sorry nah it's it's a little bit
like there's a grooviness to um american gangster
uh with denzel washington russell crowe
um which is a period film in the 70s but
um about frank lucas uh who sold heroin in new
york um but there's a grooviness to that movie
where you're like oh there's like a sense of humor
to it but it's also serious about what they're
talking about and there's a grooviness to like
ocean's eleven and there's a great sense of humor
but then it doesn't have that serious component
right it never gets really serious ever
um and so the film we were working on had a tone
of that um but anyway to make a long story long
um we wrote the script and they said hey you can
you can sell it on spec or you could do something
with it and i had time between commercials or
between a music video and a commercial and i said
hey let's let's just shoot some scenes from it so
it's sort of billed as a short film and it's not
it's it's a short film has to have a beginning
middle and a short film whether it's five minutes
or 11 minutes has to have act one act two x-ray it
has to right and this doesn't this has this kind
of like picks up sort of in the beginning of act
two and then it ends and it and and you meet the
thief uh under circumstances which are very very
odd where he has to prove a painting is real or
not and his life is in the balance and then um he
is recruited after doing that to steal the real
one because he proves that the one they're looking
at to fake and uh um so we shot this kind of like
kind of like you take a script and you're like
hey we're gonna shoot page seven through twelve
right so we did and um uh after that experience
um i got another uh another gig came up for me
and then after i shot that i went to new zealand
and so we kind of put that all on ice and also we
we polished that script the guy who we co-wrote
it and um and he did a big polish of the script
and it's probably like a 20 million dollar film
so it's on ice because it's like hey man that
opportunity is not knocking at my door right now
and i'm not gonna undershoot it like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna bring the scope of the script down
to like three or four million dollars because it
needs to be what it is right so now you have to
have that discipline of did we spend all this
time on this script and is it ever going to get
made or was that just really exciting during that
period of our lives so it's been on the shelf for
like six years yeah that's the danger of when you
put something on imdb they're like oh my gosh this
must have been like an official official official
thing and you're like no dude i just it was a
great project and we had a good time doing it and
it is a very very interesting story we're
passionate about so when people do ask us about it
which is infrequent um you guys totally did your
uh r d here uh when people do ask us about it it's
something where we're like you know you want to
drop kind of like a easter egg or a breadcrumb and
be like yeah hey look for that in five years or or
whenever we get 20 million dollars to shoot it so
anyway there are other priorities between now and
then sure so yeah just a few meetings away right
yeah yeah but you used a lot of the people or some
of the people uh in that art thief heist movie
to then co-write and then be an echo is that
right um so the lead actor in the art portrait
of an art thief's name is lathrop walker and he's
the leading actor in echo um but he and i have
been friends for 16 years we went to acting school
together he's an extremely talented actor we lived
together when i lived in la so it's sort of that
ben affleck matt damon thing we we co-wrote some
stuff we wrote stuff individually um and so what
happened with ekka was he and i co-wrote the story
sort of a treatment that developed over
over some time and i took the treatment and
needed to have a script development session
that was really my voice as a writer director
but we both built that story and we've we've
written several treatments together of films
that are coming up um but my relationship right
now with the way i need to work is i need to
write the script because the way i'm going to
write it is the way i'm going to shoot it right
and what i mean by that is to give you a couple of
examples like if you read the script to prisoners
or if you read the script to science of the lambs
or 7 or blade runner 2049 you're reading the work
of screenwriter's interpretation of that story and
the visuals and the scope of that story but the
no directors contributed to that script so if you
read that script you're going to read it just like
a script now if you read anything that christopher
nolan writes or michael mann or james cameron
you're reading a script from a writer
director and the tone and the style
of the writing is going to be very different
because those writer directors are writing it
because that's the way they're going to see it
and that's the way it's going to be interpreted
and those documents without being cold about
it those documents are very very different
uh i have a friend who writes for marvel
and he has read everything i've ever written
and um he's like you're gonna shoot this dude
you're totally gonna shoot this and i'm like
yeah of course i am and he's like yeah
because you write he's like you write it
like there are no other ways for me to
interpret the visual language of this film
and so my relationship with lathrop is we have we
have a co-writing relationship in the story phase
of things that's highly organized and highly
developed and we've tried to co-write scripts
together we've tried once or twice and and the the
the way of working didn't work for me personally
and had nothing to do with his creative energy or
his uh genius as a storyteller he's very brilliant
very layered storyteller it had to do with the
voice of the script it had to do with the way i
wanted everything of the dialogue to sound or the
way i wanted to interpret the scene description of
presenting to the reader the way i want the film
to be and um so we did co-write the story to echo
um and i've known for a long time that i wanted
to cast him as a leading man in my first film
i trust him implicitly it's the same vice versa
we've worked together on short films as you know
we've worked together on commercials we've worked
together on music videos we worked together on
a very very intense action music video that was
kind of like narc and traffic together and he was
a very interesting character he's classically
trained actor so when we talk about character
development we're talking like two actors are
talking to each other right it's it's not top
down like sometimes they'll be on a set and
you'll watch a director be like i think you
should be nicer just be nicer and and and actors
like i don't know what tell that means you know so
he and i have this relationship that we have this
incredible shorthand director to actor and we're
best friends so we it's just this brotherhood
thing and uh um when people see echo they see
what michael lathrop's character goes through
in the film and that's a tall ask if that guy
was a movie star uh for for for a movie star or an
a-list actor to go through that with a first-time
director would be a super tall ask but that's
not what i thought about when i cast him when i
when i wrote michael in the script i wrote
it for him he was going to do it um so the
other aspect of your question was other people
i worked with on art thief helena grace donald
interestingly enough when um i went to uh
they have these um you know what they are and
um you know these acting master classes right
right so there's these showcases where actors
come from all over the world to hollywood
or la and they work with a acting teacher
and there are some that are great and then
there are some that are like gurus without
mentioning the ones i've gone to because those are
my opinions i've gone to a few that are fantastic
and i've gone to a few that were not a good use
of time and i went to one that was fantastic
and i watched uh i went with a casting
director who said um and this is years
ago this is before we did art thief
we were casting for something else
and she said hey i want you to take a look at some
people and i said all right and i watched probably
14 scenes and out of those so it's 14 scenes times
two actors out of like 30 actors or whatever 28
she just blew me away and when she was like 20
like 19 or 20 from london and uh i said you know
hey let's let's talk to her and um i was right
about to i do we just pulled those pages from
art thief we're like hey man we're gonna give
this a go uh and there's a character who's a
who's the daughter of a powerful billionaire
art collector and she collects black market
art and she doesn't really care how it is
acquired she's a character that when we wrote
it she was like in her mid-30s and she was um
we were always imagining like cate blanchett
we were always imagining a powerhouse who
could just with one word or look could just
hook you and uh i told helena about the character
i said you know i'd like you to read with lathrop
lathrop plays the art thief and i said you
know i really need you to convey that level of
gravitas and power and she's threatening him
for most of the film and that's a very tall ask
and she just killed it and i said okay great
so she was in it and she was fantastic her and
lathrop had a lot of great chemistry and and then
we worked on one other small project together we
tested for something for one of the studios and
and then she went off and did a couple movies
and i went to new zealand and then
when i came back from new zealand um
we were casting for echo and i called her and i
said hey i wrote this role and i thought of you
for it and you don't need to audition but here's
the scoop you know and i told her about it and
right away it was a very wise decision and uh
and again their their chemistry and echo is
very very dense and it's um it's fragile there's
magnetism between them that can only come from
really enjoying the scene work with someone
else you know you have people who don't give
you any juice if it's not their coverage right
and they are actors who are absolutely present
with each other and so that comes across in echo
big time but only those only those two actors yeah
when did you start writing the screenplay for
echo six months before we started shooting
so what what happened was we wrote the story to
like i said i wrote several scripts when i was in
new zealand all of which were uh beyond what our
investment group had put together so they were
kind of like films that were outside the scope of
what i could execute so i said okay great these
will just have to hold so then we collaborated on
a very interesting uh um script and we wrote that
and it and then i took a a big pass at that draft
of that particular film and i got to the end of
it and i said it's the same issue it's too big for
what we can shoot so i put that on the shelf and i
said i really really really wanted to do that but
it's just not the right time which takes a lot of
discipline and you have to kind of like get over
it pretty quick so then we sat down and i said he
had this idea so i i sent him two page id i was
like yeah i have an idea bang bang bam bam bam
and he was like oh that's super
interesting and then he came back to me
and said well what if it's set here and here and
here so we went through a couple of versions of
that treatment where at one point the film was set
in a hotel that was very time oriented um sort of
like a ticking time bomb of a film and then we
expanded that and we got the treatment to a place
where we both felt like we really understood the
characters and then i said okay i want to write
this and he's like for sure man so i um wrote it
in i think i did four drafts of the script and
uh and then we were in pre-production
because we had a timeline on our capital so
so um we didn't have a release date we had
a certain amount of capital put together and
there was a time timeline on that capital the
other thing that was super critical in his life
and this is personal but you people can figure it
out pretty quickly is his wife was pregnant with
their first child so we had this capital
constraint and then we had a life constraint
and so we had this um you know in the can
deadline that we were working against and uh
so yeah six months and how did you get access to
the capital how are you you could be are you in
new zealand flying back and forth to la i think at
that time yeah no no at that time i had moved back
uh i had moved back full time and uh by then
when i moved back i had a business model in
my mind of what i wanted to do and i was super
clear about well i had had the business model
for years and along with writing in new zealand
i had done a lot of research i had done a lot
of research with studios there i've done a
lot of research with film distributors there
what works what doesn't work how does a
film make money how does it lose money
um and built a business plan there while
we were running this ad agency and um
so i came back from new zealand and
i was like this is what we're doing
and um so then i put together an investment group
out of seattle there's a couple people in new
york but it's mostly in seattle so basically i sat
down with people that i knew who trusted me a lot
and i said this is what we're going to do
and they said awesome the biggest challenge
the biggest hurdle i had wasn't trust and it
wasn't execution or they didn't think i was
going to make a product that didn't live up to the
standards of what they saw on my commercial reel
they thought about time you know there's a lot
of time variables with film like when's the
script going to be ready what if you get rained
out of a location what if someone gets hurt
etc from a producer's perspective there's tons
of variables which in an investment world is
called risk management and so we developed a
very very calculated risk management strategy
so all those folks felt like their capital
was protected and uh and then we met those
we met those requirements and beyond as
far as budget goes and time goes and i
credit a lot of my um well i credit all of my
commercial production experience with staying on
target and um being relentless with deadlines and
so forth and so yeah it was a very tight timeline
um and there were times when that was that
there were times when that felt like it was um
reckless a couple times meaning our goal was
to achieve something in this amount of time
and and every once in a while there is this
there is this thundering hammer of reality
which was like you didn't know this no matter
how many ads you've shot no matter where you
shot no matter what conditions you've shot under
and that's when that's when you realize this is
this is 32 days this is not two or three this is a
feature um and and so that that period of time was
a reckoning what were some of the recurring
questions you were trying to ask yourself while
writing echo i think the the recurring question
i wanted to ask myself was why is this personal
for the main character the genre that i wanted
to work under which is the spy thriller genre
is very well tread very very worn there
are not a lot of trails to be blazed there
so i wanted it to be a portrait i started
there i started okay this needs to be
very intimate um about the main character and
why he needs to know what he needs to know and
so and it expanded from there thematically to
me which was he needs to know where he came from
not because he has amnesia or something
like jason bourne but he needs to know
where he came from because he is going to be
a father and his wife is pregnant in the film
and she's very far along um but they're
balancing their life with the fact that
he's a crab fisherman so he's gone for months at
a time and one of the reasons why i wrote him as
a crab fisherman was um i know a lot of fishermen
and they will tell you that there are a lot of um
you know interesting people on those boats there
there are nomads there are outlaws there are
people that are fugitives and there are captains
of those boats who make a decision about whether
or not they're going to pay someone in cash or
in check and so forth generally speaking the
industry is very above board so i don't want to
come across as someone who's disparaging to the
fishing industry which is extraordinary but
there are there are people you meet who you
say man i really wonder about his past and i was
in a bar and i was writing i was expanding this
character who was a former assassin and i was
talking to my friend who's a former fisherman
and we were at a fishing bar so to speak and i
started to look around and i started to see him
in these faces i started to see like he's these
this guy's running from something and that guy's
running from something and i wonder if that
guy's done time like hard time right and um
so i went back and looked at some of the research
methods that michael mann used for his first film
thief and some of the research he did for miami
vice and for l.a crime story and for heat which
is my favorite film of all time uh and he really
talked to people who are criminals they talk to
people who are cops and talk to people who are
dealers and so forth so i was like all right i'm
really gonna the questions i'm gonna ask myself
are why does he matter why would i believe this
why would he go from being a professional high
level killer who's paid to do this and works for a
clandestine organization to working on a fishing
boat so i kept asking myself you know how can we
keep this grounded you know how can we keep this
story believable um what ended up happening was
in the script was the film became a love story
and i think some audience members have really
responded well to that you know i think they
really think the film is beautiful i think some
audience members expected john wick 4 you know
they expected uh a smash action picture with stunt
sequences and it's not that and in the marketing
we tried to make it more beautiful and in the
way we promised to deliver the film to the
audience we tried to talk about its love story and
the complications of that and so the questions
i kept asking myself when i was writing it was
um if this man's going to be a father then he
has to know his beginning too and and if someone
found him right if he wants to live in obscurity
and if he wants to be a ghost and have a quiet
life if someone found him who knew truth what
would he do what would he do to protect that
and and that's where everything started
because the treatment later open i had
was the story of the film but that's not the
motivation for a character that's like this
happens and this happens and this happens and
this happens and then it ends like this right
and it was very interesting because when i went to
go write the script the ending changed um when i
went to go write it the relationship between who
his father was changed uh and the organization
went from being sort of a global question mark
empire or organization like terrell corporation
and blade runner or wallace corporation and blade
runner 2049 we're like wow this is this ubiquitous
like evil apple right and it changed completely
to like this very private family-owned company
that's protecting its interests so everything
became more grounded and i kept asking myself
how can i make this more of a portrait of of
one man's life instead of making it about like
corporate espionage which it does have in
it so why did you need to tell this story
wow it's like asking me why i have to breathe um
i knew from doing years of ads i knew from writing
both in seattle and los angeles and new zealand
that all of the energies of those pursuits
were pointing me towards um making a feature
and crossing over so to speak like crossing the
line from ads to you know doing from doing sprints
to a marathon and um everything anybody tells you
about shooting a film uh about its rigor and its
sheer impossibility is true um from
my experience it's true and i remember
the drive of we started this now we have
to finish it and the feeling that we could
you know we had all the right people to make a
complicated very very layered story come to life
um and then um internally i had to push myself
as hard as i could ever like it's like doing
200 commercials in a month right and and keeping
a balance and a discipline for the work and my
visual aesthetic and the cinematographer calls
me we are very close and he's and he says
he says you are the guardian of the image and
what that means is it's a very high compliment
but more importantly than being a compliment
what he means is i'm looking at everything for
every shot for everything and i storyboard
everything i call every lens on every shot
um and so i think i had to kind of have this um
um baptism by fire um any of those awesome phrases
um but it but it was also climbing a mountain i've
used that metaphor a lot to the point of i'm sure
if some people watch this who know me they'll
be like oh he's talking about mountains again
but there are times i've read a
lot of books uh i've read a lot of
true story biographies about different climbers
and there are times they talk about moving in a
group getting to base camp moving to this
other camp moving to this other elevation
and then they talk about like summiting or getting
somewhere where they climb in the dark or they
climb alone and that's why i had to do it i had to
i had to finish it and i had to get to the top and
there's still no sense of satisfaction or pride or
any of that it's just it's like that quiet feeling
of you did it but it doesn't feel good like it
doesn't feel like joyful you know it feels like
it feels like you're more obsessed
than ever to do it again so six months
to finish the script for echo so you started
with i know you said the ending changed at
some point yeah are you outlining what
are you doing to begin this script um
i started with the first image of what i
wanted the audience to see which also changed
and i started with the pacing and um that's one
thing that's very important that people know and
the marketing team could have done a better job
with this and they they focused on other things
the pacing of it is reminds you of like a
european crime film it's not an american
like i said action picture so i started with that
which is like what's the tone of this when people
are talking with each other are they saying what
they mean or are they lying and most of the scenes
they're saying what they think they can say
but there's a lot of other meaning so for
example i knew that a two-page dialogue
scene was going to clock to like three
and a half minutes on film because
i needed to give actors room to work
and so i took the treatment uh which was it was
i would say it was thorough in some places and
not thorough in other places i'll give you
an example of that the treatment that we
do that we did and that we do has no dialogue in
it and that's because the style of the dialogue
i write is very specific and most of the time
what it is is what's not said and that takes
tremendous acting talent to nail and some audience
members love that sense of like i'm watching their
look and it's not telling me the thing but then
it's going to an hour later and other audiences
members don't like that they want to be like
you know they want it to be very on the nose
i'm not going to be able to deliver the thing they
want i'm always going to deliver that other thing
so i remember starting to build um there there
are uh there's a timeline structure to the film
there's a there's a um there's him in his life
and then there's what he's remembering about his
um past and there are mirrors in the whole film
so i remember building the mirrors in the script
first and then being like okay this scene into
this into this and he's remembering this how
and this is how we're showing his memory and this
is how we reveal that um and i also was building
a layered script in that the audience it's an
invitation for the audience to do work it's not
it's not a very simple film to follow and that's
by design i mean kubrick and nolan these are
these are screenwriters not talking about their
directing which is masterful i'm talking about
their screenwriting they're demanding they
say i'm going to show you i'm going to tell
you a story but you got to be in it you got to
be into this journey one of the things we were
joking around about it the premiere was no one
can go to the bathroom if you go to the bathroom
don't come back because you're gonna miss
something right obviously if you're in a
cinema you can't control stopping a film so when
it's on vod people can stop it or on blu-ray um
so yeah so so um i i started
with structuring everything
and structuring the way things were
going to be revealed and then i went into
writing some scenes dialogue very
meticulously some of those scenes they just
you know you're like a channel you're like i
know exactly what they say and i know exactly
why they say it and then other scenes um i'm i
always err on the side of no dialogue i always
err on the side of i don't think people need to
talk to say anything so the script was very short
at first the first pass was like 78 pages and then
the final script was like 94 and the movie's two
hours so that means i'm a visual director that it
shows a lot of information without people talking
and um so yeah that's that's how i began
my process by structure and then dialogue
and then um polishing the dialogue and then
polishing the way i wanted the script to be read
quentin tarantino says something great
i'm going to paraphrase it because i
don't know the exact quote but he says a
script should be enjoyable for the reader
you know whether it's made into a film or
not they should read it and enjoy reading it
and that's important for me i'm very i'm
very um turned on by even seeing description
not being overly written but being specific
and being character driven even and um
yeah so those are the things i start with and you
knew you had this finance sort of ticking clock
so where is lathrop putting in his is he really
just doing more the back story on his character
how is he getting involved um we had uh getting
involved in the script uh he didn't until there
was a final script so basically i took when i said
i'm going to take it and i'm going to write it
i'm going to write it and that's why it says
written by me right and it's not an ego trip it's
like it's it's written and directed by me because
that's the way it's going to be right however um
once there was a solid draft right which
is like draft number dose you know um uh i
he read it and we sat down and we talked about
it you know i said hey do you have any questions
you know let's talk about it you know and he was
just starting to get into developing his character
pretty thoroughly so he's not coming at it from
a writing perspective he's coming at it from an
acting perspective and then what i told him i
wanted to do was hey i said hey as i audition
a person for this role or this role or this role
he may or may not be in the audition right uh
he will he'll definitely not be in the audition
he'll be in the callback maybe or he'll be in
like the screen test chemistry read right and i
said hey so you know i'm watching these carefully
and i'm revising as i go because i'm watching
an actress's interpretation of a line
and she's doing her art in that call
back and you can get ideas from that
she's not she's not improving she's not ad-libbing
but she might take a pause that's not there
or she might go through the scene and you might
be like oh man i gotta cut a third of this i
don't need a third of this that's never usually my
problem usually what it is is something's missing
some maybe an extra line here of clarification um
and uh um he had he had i would say he had like a
handful of notes um that were helpful because
he's like what about this or what about that
or or he'd say i remember in one uh screen
chemistry read he he did two or three lines
in a row and he switched them up every time and
he didn't switch them up because he doesn't know
his lines because he's perfect in that capacity he
switched them up because he's like let me try this
and i was like yeah man and they were better and
so you go okay cool that's great um and then uh
the other thing that happened with the
script uh was um after it was in the can
i knew when the film was shot i was like i
know i need to restructure this in the cut
so my structuring of events in the script
were the pacing wasn't right for what we got
and that's a reality of the relationship between
what you think is going to work on the page and
what you get on the day and what you get in your
assembly and your assembly is the truth and um uh
there's no you know you can read something on a
page 100 times and be like this is going to work
totally it's totally going to work totally and
then you shoot it and you go something was weird
about today or something's weird about the movie
you're putting together in your mind as you as you
shoot i'm building the movie right in my head and
i know i know it's going to come before and after
something i know the pacing of a moment and you're
on set that day and you're like man something's
not working and i don't know what it is yet and
then you put an assembly together and you go i
know exactly what the problem is and you make
two choices there you restructure the cut with
the material you have and we had a lot of great
material so 80 of the story restructuring could
happen in the cut and then you figure out what's
missing because of time or because you didn't
know you wanted to add those shots to the story
and and i knew we knew when we started day one
that we were going to do pickups and reshoots we
knew that before we even started not like a studio
that might do two months or what have you i don't
know you know or reshoot a whole like world war z
they shot like the last third of the movie again
but i knew that we were going to do a few days
and as the assembly came together that that two
or three days turned into six days and it really
allowed me to and it was it was a it was mostly um
pickups it was not re-shoes we only did the stuff
we re-shot was like insert stuff that i wanted
something tighter of or um or a flashback moment
i wanted something more significant of so those
are the reshoots but everything else was shots
that i knew i wanted during production that i was
like i'm going to get those later on and so yeah
what makes a great story i think what makes a
great story for me i have two different responses
to this question because i love film i love movies
and i love a lot of different kinds of movies if
you look at what my collection is or if you ask me
for like a top 10 list it's quite curated around
my sensibilities and what i want to re-watch
and what i want to study for future craft yeah
but if you looked at those you'd still see a lot
of different kinds of stories and so first of all
i'd say that something about what the character
must accomplish turns you on like you can see
yourself in him or her what they have to do is
very very very interesting to you and generally
speaking the kind of stories i like the stakes are
incredibly high you know we're talking about life
and death we're talking about someone figuring
out a big piece of information about their life
if you look at the scripts that we have in
development and if you look at my next couple
of projects you see that all of these from a
stakes perspective 0-10 are a 9 right at least
and that's because there's a contrast between your
life your life every day right that ticks away and
however you spend your day and then when
you go and watch a piece of entertainment
and i think that um the films that last for me
are ones where the stakes are very very high
and where the protagonist doesn't know
something very important and that doesn't
need mean it needs to have o henry ending or
an m night shyamalan twist or what have you
there's this devotion to learning about their
journey and uh so a great story i think has those
components i'm a bit of a romantic and um so i
look at the fact that the protagonist is involved
in some kind of love story or love conflict or
is also dealing with you know they're kind of
dealing with a macro conflict and they're dealing
with micro conflicts because that's super real
and where a story loses me is if there are no
micro conflicts if it's just i gotta go to the
end of this place and kill all these people and
that's it then it it it loses me you know i'm very
entertained by john wick i have a tremendous
amount of respect for those filmmakers a
tremendous amount of respect for all the training
they do and their execution the truth of it for me
as a writer director is i enjoy all of the ways
they execute that concept of a movie but i walk
out of that film and i stop thinking about it
you know i stop i get my car and i drive away
and i oh yeah there's a pearl jam and i suddenly
that's it i think the most interesting stories um
that i'm trying to write and shoot and make into
work and the most interesting stories that are in
the collection of films i was mentioning
are stories that have layers that don't
serve you maybe everything you need the first
viewing and so in addition to uh you know high
high stakes in their macro objective in addition
to the protagonist dealing with the truth of a
real relationship in the story i think the third
thing for me is that um there has to be a sense of
intellectual structure to the story it has
to make me think about the world they're in
or make me think about the inner workings of
that protagonist or make me think about or
question my own relationship because of the amount
of truth in that story you know sometimes you
you are in a marriage or relationship and you
watch a marriage or relationship on screen and
there's this profound truth in the script and
in the acting and the directing and it makes you
reflect on yourself and those are the three things
i really look for in a great story definitely
there's an article i read i have it saved in
a folder that i go to sometimes when i need to
come out of the darkness like out of editorial
or out of like a writing um period and i i go
back to it when i need to sort of shake uh
the reality tree you know where you say hey
what i'm doing is really important or what i'm
doing is myopically obsessive in this particular
scene that i'm writing or this particular moment
we're cutting and editorial and the article is an
interview with david fincher and the title is you
better be [ __ ] serious because that's probably
one of the big turn-ons for me is i work with
people who are very serious about this work and
so i've had a very interesting relationship
having not been on any panels uh i don't know
if it's because people don't like me but i think
it might also be because there's like a um there's
like a devotion to the technical practicality
of execution that's what i want to talk about i
want to talk about doing the thing i don't want
to talk about the thing you know and so maybe
someday people would be interested in what i have
to say we'll see when you pull up that article
yeah what does it do for you i'm sure it varies
from time to time like how does it make me feel um
it's like a it's like a mentor i don't have you
know it's like a person where you say hey man am i
on the right track here you know am i like blinded
am i missing out on life because i'm taking
this work so seriously and it's a reminder from
a craftsman who i have the highest regard for um
that i should just keep going and that sometimes
it's really lonely and sometimes um it's very
isolating um and then sometimes there are people
who have no connection to the industry and you
engage with them whether they're your friends
or your family and they don't understand why
you care so much about what you're doing and
then two years later they see your film and they
maybe they understand a little but they still
don't so the article reminds me that i'm on
the i'm on the war path and just keep going and
being a little bit removed from the entertainment
industry being in washington state i know there's
a lot of artists up there yeah there's music or
fine art whatever i live there most of the
time but i'm here all the time but you're
here all the time okay so we're sort of like
dual residence sort of uh it's probably like
at this stage it's probably like 75 25. 80 20
something like that you know so so then you go
to another you're you're at least being exposed to
both areas and you're seeing a different mindset
yeah and so you're not probably hearing about
yeah so we're working on this screenplay it's
the local market that you're frequenting or yeah i
had this call back or whatever right so does that
help you does that help you stay more in quote
the real world or do you not feel as motivated
because you're not hearing about the industry all
around you at all times that's a great question um
for my personality which is driven by myself like
i don't need someone to kick my ass every day
i think that having the dissonance having
the distance also away from hollywood is
a real positive thing for the way i work um i
think that there's a way to get distracted in the
labyrinth of the way the industry wants to give
people value um and the way they want to create um
energy and hope which when i was living
here full-time i found the energy
and hope that was being created was a
very uh double-edged sword i felt like
the energy and hope that was being created for for
me when i lived here was optimism it was fueling
my tank it made me want to meet great actors and
great producers it made me want to try to move my
career forward the flip side of the coin is you're
exposed to the fact that every door is locked
to you whether you're a director or an actor
or a producer and that there are only a certain
number of ways to get a key um and so going
to new zealand offered me a reprieve from that
search i didn't have to think about like how
was i going to get a key to talk to someone at
village road show or how was i going to get a
key to go down and talk to the people at weta
you just go i mean you call and you talk to
them and decide if they want to meet you etc
and i really benefit from creating my work
elsewhere and not being part of the um machine
with its highs and lows with the way
that it decides it's going to tell me
that my work's valuable um however i think
the industry is tremendously interesting
i i think the entertainment industry is the one of
the most unique business models in the whole world
and there's discipline about understanding it and
respecting it that i think it's very easy to it's
very easy to get angry about not being able
to get a key to the door and you can't get in
and then being really pissed off about that and
then saying you know [ __ ] hollywood and having
that attitude and i don't have that attitude
at all i really i respect it when i drive down
highland and i see the dolby theaters advertising
i'm like i know why that's there and i know what
it's doing to uh add value and build the profile
of that studio's release i get all that right
but so far i have had the opportunity to work with
people here in sort of a satellite capacity where
i come to town i work with them where i come to
town and we talk about what we're going to do
and then i leave and i go home and that's been the
best process for me and it's been super rewarding
it's also allowed me to look at the machine
of hollywood with a different focal length
you know and i've actually learned to
have a much better sense of humor about it
you know and i think when i lived
here i didn't when i lived here i was
i was so focused on making my way towards one
of those doors that i didn't step back and
try to just look at it all and think about
how it all works it's an incredible watch
it's an incredible mechanism with so many
variables um and there are a lot of very very
smart people here and there are a lot of people
here who are full of a lot of darkness and um
it will always be interesting whenever i'm flying
in whenever i'm coming into town and i get off of
kuanga by a hollywood bowl i'm whenever
i drive into hollywood i'm always like uh
yeah yeah start looking behind the veil do you
mind me asking why you left l.a i know you were
flying to new zealand which was doing this
advertising marketing and then at what point
did you leave la for good or not for good
right you're open to coming back yeah i
think i think it was never like i'm never going
back there again i think my relationship with
i mean essentially my relationship with how much
time i had to spend here changed and it's never um
it's never gone back to being full-time
so my opportunities in new zealand my
opportunities were shooting a lot around the world
regarding that new zealand australia london etc
they were far more interesting than me being
here hitting the pavement and maybe not getting
a key to that door it was like about building my
craft and having time to write in a place that
is one of the most beautiful countries in the
whole world and it was a refueling of the soul
and then when i came back i knew that
i wanted to shoot a film right away and
i wasn't going to shoot it here for
infrastructure reasons for cost reasons
for relationship reasons i had more
relationships in the pacific northwest
but there are a lot of people on the talent
side and the management side and the legal side
and the distribution side of course that i
work with here so i come back regularly and
a goal of mine outside of the immediate path
is to work with a studio you know definitely i
would like to have the right group of producers at
the studio i would like to have the right amount
of support and i'm very interested in that part
of the experience where i can bring what i do in
my process and my drive and my thoroughness to
a studio project because the way they operate
their protocols their timelines are so fascinating
and i you know i finished the film in los angeles
at e-film so i was working side by side with
other directors who were on studio movies
and we were all in the same kayak you know my
studio was not or my film was a non-studio picture
theirs were so for example when we were doing rdi
it was the cinematographer and i alone in a room
next door they were doing a very large budget
picture and there was 20 people in the room
so that's the big difference is
their protocols and their operations
involve more support they also involve more people
whose opinions matter to that product and i think
working in the parameters of that would be very
very interesting when the time's right and i also
kind of look at it like if anyone's interested
in in my work and in our work that we're doing
they're going to want to have that trust in my
filmmaking style and in my execution to be able
to trust me with a real significant budget
so the goal you know the end-all be-all goal
is not necessarily to work at or for a studio
but i'm truly interested in wanting to do that
as part of the journey because their parameters
for success and the way they support you
is very different than when you're an
independent did you shop around the script
for echo to production companies no and so that
was never a plan you had this business model that
you developed for a few years yep and you knew
certain people that would maybe say yes to it
maybe say yesterday how in terms of being an
investor there were group people different
our investment group is not a one-off thing you
know our investment group is a slate of movies
and um so the way i structured the model was like
a startup like a tech startup where you say we're
going to make this product we're going to go to
market here here are revenue opportunities and
none of the investors that i have in our our
team uh have ever invested in film before
and they don't have some strong opinion coming
out of a sundance market or a a con market
they've invested in technology companies and
they've invested in equity firms and et cetera
and so the model turned them on because it was
a company that builds its own asset and owns the
asset and sells the asset globally and it was just
coincidental that the asset is a film so that's
part of the pitch is i don't really talk about
making movies they're all passionate about it
they're all interested in it they loved echo
every one of the investors responded very well to
the final film which is super critical
but no one was ever no one read the script
no one asked to read it and if they had asked
it i asked i wouldn't have given it to him
because that diverts the path of what we're
doing you know the path is so singular
and there uh morgan freeman once said don't accept
criticism from someone whose feedback you wouldn't
ask for and so it's like i wouldn't ask you know
john doe investor for feedback on a script because
you know what would be the point of that
and that's no disrespect super super smart
smart brilliant people in this team
so you keep it as efficient as you can
and then you pay really close attention to how
the process went pay really close attention to
every aspect of selling the film and um and then
we stay on the path so yeah you had a lawyer draft
up all these documents and agreements and for
the company for for also for these investors
yeah yeah so i have an entertainment attorney
in los angeles and i have a securities attorney
in seattle so the securities attorney knows
nothing about films what they know about is
building an investor's package for whether you're
doing a startup or a seed round or a series a and
you just have to know what you're doing when
you talk to people about investing in a film
probably one of the most painful things i've
experienced has been you know i've been to
sundance i've been to tiff i've been to um a
couple of other film festivals that are sort
of big sif and yeah yeah i had a couple
of shorts and stuff when i was younger
but stiff isn't is in a marketplace right and
nobody buys a movie because it went to sif
they buy a movie because it goes to one of the
selling festivals but um but i remember having
experience where i was watching a film and i
was near a producer and their primary investor
and the film was not good and um wasn't executed
well and you could tell from their conversation
that they didn't have a marketing plan they
had no sales plan they had no release plan
they were at sundance on a lot of luck maybe
they knew some people sundance gives great
films opportunities and they try certain films
out and that's awesome that's what they do
but i remember that experience vividly that this
investor had put a lot of cash into a film that
didn't meet their standard of any film and there's
no way they're getting any of that back and so
and that was that was in 2007 or 2008
or something and um i remember that like
seared in my mind that if i do this you
know independently that i have to come
to the table with a plan that brings confidence
and um takes this stuff real [ __ ] seriously
a lot david fincher so yeah are your
parents entrepreneurs did you watch them
build companies or my parents are super super hard
working uh i watched their work ethic i watched um
their uh they're both in education my dad was
the superintendent of public school districts
uh with a phd my mom has a master's in
child psychology and um uh taught um
special ed preschool kindergarten first grade
these are wonderful wonderful people who
make the world a better place and they're very
supportive of this i think there's a reality of
it's out of their wheelhouse you know it's
outside their wheelhouse of wanting to start an
equity company it's outside their wheelhouse of um
wanting to spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
on an illusion of entertainment that you'll sell
to people i think that there's something really
practical and beautiful about every day you
go into a classroom and you lift a mind up
or you take care of someone that needs
that and um but they always supported my
madness and um but there's not there's not
a connective there's not a parallel between
their lives and their careers and anything i'm
doing sometimes i think that's exciting for them
uh other times i think it's curious
other times i think that it's um
there's like a sense of there's a
sense of they and they're very deep
beautiful philosophical people and when we were
young as kids um they said to us even when we
were very young they said you know do something
that feeds your soul right they didn't say go
to law school yeah they didn't say that and
um so as this has been evolving they've seen
they've seen a path that has had swaths of
distance between success and trying things out and
travel and i've always been on the move and so i
think it's interesting for them to watch this come
to life and uh and they both reacted very very
well to echo and i think that they were kind of
there's a sense of not knowing
like is this real is what he's doing really
real you know they've seen my commercial work
and stuff so no that's real but you know an
endeavor that takes years in the making um
they there was a sense of like waiting uh of is
this gonna be any good and so i think there was um
without them knowing through and through
everything about the industry i think they were
very excited that it it was finished at the level
it was finished at and that it's the beginning you
know they know i'm working on another film already
and so they're excited to i remember my mom just
saying you know after she saw the film she had a
lot of questions about the film she wanted to see
it again right away which is the perfect response
enjoying it and wanting to see it again that's the
best reaction to echo people can have but she also
had a lot of questions about what i was doing next
she's like this film is very complicated
and very interesting and very beautiful so
what are you gonna do next what could you
possibly want to do next you know and that
was a wonderful reaction you know um and i'm super
fortunate to i've got a great family and they have
supported this um all through my decisions to
do this kind of work without understanding it
from an insider's perspective you know they're
looking at it from the outside and they're still
supporting it which is really it's a
privilege to have that kind of support yeah
so with your co-collaborator on echo lathrop
walker did he train for the assassin sort of
scenes like oh yeah um oh yeah um so we did two
types of training for lathrop to become michael
he's a very uh fit and very skilled actor and he's
very physically oriented actor he's done tons of
physical training as far as embodying a
character and developing them physically
so i knew that he was going to make him specific
which is a tall order in this particular script
but two things that he's not is he's not an
assassin and he's also not someone who can
hurt someone else with their bare hands so we
divided up his training into weapons training and
into stunt work and the way the weapons training
worked was we sent them to itts which is in simi
valley which is an internet international tactical
training group they train special operatives they
train swat they train hrt they train actors
and i did a lot of research around who would
teach him as quickly as possible but who would
be very serious and very accountable for his
learning now he's super serious as an actor and
he's very committed to it however if we have a
short period of time you need to have a teacher or
a coach who's gonna hammer you so that you become
good quickly and they did that you know he did
several sessions they're going from learning how
to handle a handgun all the way up to learning
how to handle an assault rifle and he went from
a guy who um you know you just would never see
him with a gun at home he would never have a gun
he went from that to being absolutely
lethal with every weapon he was touching
there are videos we're training videos we have on
youtube that we show him doing the gun training
uh both handguns and um long rifles and then
the second group of uh stunt work we did uh i
hired a guy named adam noble who is a fight corps
coordinator he does stunts for film television
theater he's really well-rounded journeyman but
he's also expert at physical movement for actors
he's trained intensely with the suzuki method
he's trained intensely with stunt choreography
associations and fight coordinators and
he's very very good at teaching an actor
along with being a great stunt man himself so
what we did with adam adam is based in houston so
what we did was i wrote the fight in the movie the
way i wanted to see it and i sent him the pages
and he read it and then we talked about the beats
of of the fight sequences right there's three or
four of those in the film and so what adam would
do is he would take a group of students at the
university of houston in one of his movement
classes and how great is that for a young
actor to be like oh hey i'm going to use you as
a you know a hit man or as a heavy in a sequence
so we can frame and sketch the fight and so adam
would send me videos of that and i would describe
my shots or i'd send him some storyboards so he
knew i said i only want coverage of the fight
from these perspectives because that's how the
audience will see the fight and so he would send
me these these sketches and they were it was two
things that were great about them one they were
very clear about the movement like the beats you
know this happens and this happens this happens
you know nothing highly developed meaning nothing
moving at full speed really because i didn't need
to see that and the second thing about them was
his students were great if i had notes i'd be
like hey man try this and try that and he would
adapt it right away and they were up for anything
but then we a couple days before we ended up
shooting those sequences so lathrop had learned
the fight from videos lathrop trained all day
every day for a week with a group of professional
stuntmen with under adam's guidance and after a
few days they brought me in and they showed me the
fight and they had that that main fight sequence
is very quick and it happens on a dock in a marina
in a fisherman's terminal so there's a lot of
spatial constraints it's very dangerous um it's
gonna be at night it's gonna be wet etc and um so
adam had put together a great fight i wanted to be
more brutal i wanted uh it to better represent how
the character would react to being surrounded and
most importantly what's most critical about that
fight in the film is it's really from his wife's
perspective it's the first moment it's in the
trailer it's the first moment his wife watches him
and what he can do she doesn't know he can do
this he goes he goes on a fishing boat to get
his paycheck he sees some stuff on the fishing
boat which is just scary and thrilling meaning
someone is going to come and kill him and he
comes off the fishing boat and as she looks at him
and he looks at her he's surrounded by a group of
masked men who are very well trained and they're
all professional stuntmen and a couple of them are
mma fighters like these are really good fighters
and it was extraordinary to see it go from video
sketches with students of atoms into this dynamic
fight i shot the whole thing with a
technocrat so it has a sense of fluidity to it
and it's really a privilege to work with uh adam
and his team but it's also proves to work with
lathrop because he takes every movement very very
seriously uh he takes every part of the process
very seriously you see him like in the training
videos on youtube you see him like you know pack
guys on the back and help him up and he's a really
great person and that's what you want and an actor
who has to be violent towards another person
is you want them to actually have the heart of
someone who doesn't want to do this and then when
they do have to do it it's much more authentic
and he brought that fight to life and uh the way
it's shot is i'm very proud of the way it shot
because of how much it uh brings the audience into
his wife's perspective of i had no idea he was
capable of this and uh that moment affects sort of
a ripple just that pebble in the water that moment
is it ripples the rest of the film regarding
what his what he's capable of how much time did
you have for pre-production so six months writing
scripts right um well i was writing and location
scouting at the same time and that's a producer
mindset which is don't write but you can't shoot
and so i was for example i was like i want
this sequence to happen on a fishing boat
so i went down to um the fisherman's terminal in
ballard in seattle and i started walking the docks
and looking for a boat like what's the boat that i
want for this movie um and then i started looking
at the dock and i was like maybe the fight happens
here yeah the fight happens here boom and then
that's in the script and then um other things
there's there's a sequence with a private jet
and i was like okay how are we going to get
how we can pull that off and so pre-production
became quite integrated in the scripts cr uh the
scripts right script writing out of necessity
and out of i don't know i guess learning that
as a commercial director you're like okay i
got this script what can we do how can we make
it how can we build that reality right now and
um so pre-production began in earnest i
would say pre-production began in earnest
around the middle of january because that's when
we did a camera test and you start testing optics
and you start looking at what lenses are friendly
for the actor you start looking at what lenses
you're going to be framing your language with
right there's a vocabulary you're going to create
that was the middle of january and
then we started shooting on april 1st
what did you shoot on we shot on an ari alexa
and it's a great camera love it love it and
were the lenses part of the package did you
get other lenses from somewhere else uh we
well we have a great relationship with kerner
camera in seattle and i've worked with them on
commercials before i moved to los angeles
so we had great rapport so as a producer
when i was going to be shooting up there i
knew we were going to rent from them and um
so we sat down with them and we told them what our
budget was which was more than they thought it was
going to be because they're used to supporting
independent film they're used to people coming
in and say first of all used to people coming
in and asking for for free which is ridiculous
and then they're used to people negotiating rates
or asking for a certain weekly rate which is
on the verge of insulting so when we came
in we were super serious and we said this
is our budget and this is what we're going to
do and that's how long we're going to do it for
so they were on board right away uh and then
i did my test and um i tested um kawas i knew
i was gonna shoot anamorphic because i the film
demands anamorphic um and so i tested cowas which
are um older lenses uh they're very um mixed bag
as far as the quality goes of one set to another
so for example you might have a set of kawa
anamorphix where the 75 in the set is your hero
and the optics of a couple of the other like the
40 or the 100 or for example they won't perform as
well whether it's for the first ac or whether it's
for aberrations or uh whether the flare is not
working for you if that's what you're into and i
tested those primarily because i was fascinated by
how violent some of the moments are in the film
and if i wanted to incorporate optics that would
lift that up and sort of add supercharge it
so however that was kind of an outlier because
i knew that i was going to shoot cook anamorphics
as my primary set um since i started writing this
movie so yeah and then how are you lighting it
well we have a great relationship with pacific
grip and lighting in seattle they have um
a grip and electric house in portland they
have a gripen electric house in seattle and so
pacific grip and lighting we call them pgl um
they're run by it's run by a guy named ray hammond
and he is someone i've known for my entire career
so that first boxing movie that i shot on 16 with
those actors that all worked for sandwiches um
the kino that we used i think we could only afford
to rent three lights and we rented them from him
and so he and i have known each other my whole
career and when i came back and said i'm ready
to do a film and i'm the producer as well and
this is what everything looks like he gave us a
a deal that's in the realm of generosity that's
very hard to express because he believes in
me and he believes in what we're doing
and um we're very gracious and we
appreciate everything that he does i think
kind of like crooner maybe kind of like other
vendors have experienced you know sometimes
filmmakers aren't full of gratitude sometimes
they're artists to the point of ingratitude
or they just forget to acknowledge people
um we're not like that and so
rey was extraordinary in giving
our production the tools that i have
gotten used to using in commercial work
so you get used to using certain kinds
of lights you get used to using 18ks and
you get used to using sky panels etc where you're
using some of the best instruments that are made
and so we had an incredible grip
and electric package the whole movie
and he didn't know my cinematographer but
i you know talked about him and he knows
rey knows how particular and specific i am so
he recommended a gaffer for us that was local
out of seattle who's done tons of movies and is a
very awesome guy who takes no [ __ ] from anyone
and so he said i think you two are going to get
along but if you don't then don't work with them
because it won't work and he and i met for a
coffee and like in five minutes he was like oh
you're not [ __ ] around and i was like no and
his name is kevin cook he was our gaffer and
kevin brought on a key grip named mark bewing and
those two were those two created an opportunity
to create those two created an opportunity for
duncan and i to hold the bar as high as possible
right so duncan cole is my cinematographer he
and i are brothers he and i have the we work in
the spirit of spielberg and kaminsky we work in
the spirit of nolan and wally fister when that
was his dp or deakins and the coen brothers he is
uh the cinematographer that i've been looking for
for my career i've worked with a number of
cinematographers and he and i just get each other
and the reason why we get each other we're both
photographers first we're both looking at pictures
both creating pictures the second reason is we
don't reference other films when we're doing
our process creatively like when i bring my visual
reference materials to him and i say this is what
i want the sequence to look like and the color
palette's going to shift over this arc and all
that their photographs or their paintings they're
not stills from movies very rarely i will say that
i won't say never i'll say it rarely because we're
not trying to emulate another movie we're trying
to tell this story so he and i understand lighting
together very very specifically and he knows that
i'm a compositional and a aesthetically driven
director visually so we don't ever talk about
composition ever because i'm like this is what
it's gonna look like and he goes right on man
and and it's the same thing i've been on sets
before where directors don't call the lens they
don't even know the focal length they just
say i wanted to do this and that and then
the dp calls a 40 or a 50 mil or whatever and
that's the opposite i call everything and um
there were a handful of times maybe two two or
three where you said hey can we look at it on
this and i'm like yeah sure man we can look at it
on that but we're not going to shoot it on that
and he's like all right cool and it became a
joke uh because sometimes he'd want to look at
it on a 50 and i'm like we're shooting on 40.
he's like yes just look at it though and i'm
like all right cool and we'd look at it and he's
like what do you think and i'm like well we just
wasted five minutes because we're gonna shoot
it on this and it's not like a dictatorial thing
it's not like tyranny it's like i know exactly
what i want every shot to look like and why
and so so in our relationship we're beyond
that we're beyond that he is an incredible
lighting cinematographer so when we look at how
we want the lighting language of the film to be
um he communicates that directly with kevin and
mark the gaffer and the key in accomplishing that
and so from my work with duncan in the past before
we did features together we had that rapport where
i'm like it looks like this and here's why
we come around here and it's dark and super
silhouetted there and you know why he's like okay
and is that it's like that and then he goes and
we i mean this very very very meticulous process
right and then he goes this way and works with
the gaffer and the key and i go this way and work
with the actors and we're both super efficient
and he knows that he called me once he said
you are the guardian of the image and he didn't
mean you're a control freak he meant you know
exactly what you want so i don't worry about that
right he wants it to look like the way we
want it to look so he's worried about how
it's going to be lit to work that way and
from a technical perspective he and i have a
very very dynamic vocabulary together about all
the tools um not just optics or camera tools but
lighting instruments and things like that and
lighting quality and um and color we talk a
lot about color um and that's because that's
because my goal as a director is i'm gonna bake
the look into the negative i'm not going to shoot
it flat and then go into the di with a color grade
and make the color grade make the frame work right
so there's a latitude we've both talked about how
if we're working on a studio movie more than
likely we would have to shoot our films flatter
right because the studio would want to be able
to have more control in the color grade in the di
and we don't abide by that at all and a good
example of that is that we for some sequences
we use split diopters so diopters especially on
anamorphic frames diopters can be uh they can be
spherical they can be diagonal they can be pieces
of glass what the diopter does it changes the
magnification of the image so that it appears
blurry now you can accomplish that in the di
you can make a power window you can add a blur
or a gaussian blur you can make it look milky
right like a flashback or like something romantic
you can do that in post we didn't we put it on the
map box and shot it that way that's a commitment
to the image you go that's what we're doing
we're going to bake it in and if we
didn't know each other as well as we do
with that mutual trust we would make more limited
decisions we would make less committed decisions
um but uh everybody on that team on this first
feature kevin mark their teams on the grip and
on the gaff side um and the camera side uh we
all became a family they're all coming back
for the next film and uh it was interesting
for some of them who had done i won't say who
it was but it was interesting for some of them
who had worked on a lot of independent films
and working with us was different and um we
were very fortunate to have their talent because
they had probably worked on some projects they
weren't really stoked about you know they had
worked on some projects that were just jobs and
then they um came on board echo and we built this
creative team that was like everybody in like two
days everybody was like we all care about how this
is gonna be lit we care about how fast the lens
gets on that camera so i can frame up that shot
we care about the sensitivity to a dolly move you
know the vocabulary movement in a dolly on a track
or whatever and it was um i'm super grateful
for their commitment they all invested and
i think it was a testament to the
professionalism you know they saw this
ripe opportunity to be like hey man i'm
gonna give a [ __ ] and they all blew us
away with how much they cared about the film
and um so that was you know that was awesome
just how someone took a chance on you when your
mom drove you to the photographer's building right
right yeah to wait for three hours right right and
but but for some reason he saw something in you
for for those obviously it was just planning
to be it was a short meeting but it ended up
being three hours what do you see in people
that even though some may have a great resume
but you didn't just tell the work ethic isn't
there or vice versa maybe they don't you know i
remember one time i interviewed for a job and
i got it over somebody else and i asked the
person years later why did you choose me and she
said the other people they weren't hungry enough
yeah that's that's a um i mean that's a truthful
response from her i'm sure um so the question
is what do i look for in people i hire or the
question is what do i look for when i want to
work with someone again because those are sort of
different okay well then if you want to work with
them again does that boil down to work ethic or
also chemistry that's that's a great question um
i think that um
the people that blow me away
when they're hired uh and
um that i can feel a sense of energy
and commitment from right away the thing
that stands out about what they're doing is this
thing we're making this film we're making right it
is forever for me right so it's forever in the
two or three years of work leading up to making it
it's forever in that it has my artistic dna on
everything and it's forever and that it has my
name on it forever um but it's the job they're
doing maybe they maybe they've only done this
kind of work for two years or three years or
whatever i've been doing it for 14. so the
power of what i'm trying to accomplish is very
high like it's very significant to power and the
work standard is very high and the expectations
are very high i've been told that repeatedly by
people who like me and people who don't which is
your expectations are so high so what i look for
is people who want to meet those or try to exceed
them and people who care about the forever thing
you know i'm not asking them to pretend to be
me that's egotistical and ridiculous i'm asking
them to care about as many of the moments
that they're working on this is possible
and it's a tall order but i set the tone for that
and many many people uh get switched onto that
because they go oh this is this is his film
so we're gonna poof you know and that doesn't
mean that two months later they're not
gonna be working on something else and
be texting while they're doing something
else right so i look for that um focus
like this sense of focus this matters and
that they become a slightly myopic in their
execution of what they're doing they become
obsessed with getting something right
as well because that's um apple doesn't fall far
from the tree kind of thing so i look for sort of
a natural obsession of wanting to meet a really
high standard of work and it has to be consistent
there was a couple people on the set of this
picture who got super tired and whose focus
blurred uh because of the stamina of being focused
like that every day all day long is very very hard
and it's a turn off for me when it happens i'm not
inhuman people are human i get it but when i see
other people sustain their focus out of a devotion
to this project it really turns me on and it makes
me work with them again and it makes me want to
give them more responsibility depending on which
department they're in and um yeah i think
that's what i look for it's like sense of
okay for this many weeks this is what i'm
doing absolute absolute focus and commitment
knowing that it does end for them right it
doesn't end for me for quite some time but
it does end for them and there's a bunch of
people on our team who have been doing this
for so long that that turn that switch for
them of working on a project like this for
six to twelve weeks depending on which department
they're in is an easy choice because they say this
matters you know and um and i'm very lucky to have
so many of the people whose focus is super high
want to come back in a heartbeat very lucky how
terrifying was it to use the equipment that you
used on echo in terms of just the cost of the
lenses oh yeah the the re-alexa package yeah
uh not terrifying at all uh i had
used everything before um i had done a
i'd done a real significant camera test in the
months before we shot principal photography
a few months before that i had done a big project
in new zealand where we shot uh cook anamorphics
and cook s4s and before that i had shot an audi
commercial um and we shot cocanomorphics they're
extremely expensive lenses um all the tools
we use were top of the line you know we shot
alexa mini and cook anamorphics and
we used a technocrane we use an 18
a 25 and a 50. those are very very expensive
part of the privilege and benefit of doing
commercial work is it can afford you some great
toys and it can afford you the comfort of using
um you know a metaphor would be like
the best the best chef's knife possible
and i had an opportunity to use all of the
best equipment far in advance of the film
and um so i never thought about it at all
what advice do you have for a filmmaker that
is now sort of graduating to this new level and
they're terrified maybe they don't want to let
people know they don't totally know what they're
doing but they're terrified of the experience or
terrified of the gear or the gear oh of the gear
uh be well insured first of all like i hear horror
stories uh from specifically camera houses both in
seattle and panavision i know people at panavin um
and camera houses in new zealand and
australia i hear horror stories about you know
a film student or an indie filmmaker coming in
and begging and begging and begging to shoot with
a lens or a couple lenses or whatnot and they
somehow let them out or they somehow work out a
deal where they're very underinsured and suddenly
you're doing two things wrong suddenly you're
cutting a professional corner which you shouldn't
cut because if you're going to be very real at
doing this there are things you have to do right
and one of them is to be very well insured and if
you can't afford it you either need cheaper gear
that can fall under that policy you do have or you
need to wait until you can afford the right policy
because you're doing two things one you're putting
yourself at risk you're putting a relationship at
risk with the camera house where they're trusting
you and you're accepting that trust and you
actually don't have the ability to fulfill that
liability if something goes wrong and the second
thing you're doing is you're [ __ ] yourself
and your focus because if you need to direct a
movie or lens a shot and you're worried about
putting it on the camera you're wasting everyone's
time including your own um i think there is
um there's an escalation that happened for me
technically you know i shot with um i think
we shot with a rolly or a or a bolex on my first
film and then the second short i did we shot on um
on ra16s and then the next film we shot on the
435 extreme and then the next project was um a
alexa classic etc and so it kind of goes back
to like originally feeling like i don't deserve
the right to shoot something
yet right from my photography
apprentice days where i had to earn the
right shoot a shot of film i had to earn
the right to shoot a shot of film with a
hasselblad i had to earn the right to shoot
a piece of 4x5 film and which is extremely
difficult to work with um i think there's
an excitement around the tools and the toys and
stuff and that's super super natural i mean it's
very natural not supernatural it's very natural
and that's okay but if you if you can't handle
it then you shouldn't use it because your focus
needs to be about making the project a success
not about um what lens is on your camera because
nobody cares you know very few people uh very few
people outside of the film industry know the
difference between anamorphic and spherical
they don't they don't they can't tell you the
difference so they certainly couldn't tell you
the difference between a cook anamorphic and a
co-anamorphic so you have to decide the right
tool for the job and when someone's researching
production insurance policies is there like a
website you don't have to tell me like a specific
carrier but where would they go to find various
carriers i think the the best way to do it is you
can do it outside in or inside out so outside in
would be you go online and you look up film
production insurance and you make a list of
companies and you reach out to them and you do
research and you do hard work and you ask them
lots of questions you be real honest say i got 25
grand so i want to shoot short with 25 grand or
some people who are insane i'd say i want to shoot
a feature for 25 grand and they'll say what are
you renting first thing they'll say what are we
covering and you be honest with them that's again
you don't cut corners with insurance you just be
honest with them you say i'm gonna shoot an iphone
or you say i'm to shoot it with a panavision
or whatever then that's outside in you do all
the research yourself and then you catalog their
pricing their relationships right probably a more
strategic approach is you get some face time with
an account executive at like panavision hollywood
or panavision woodlawn or auto or um you know
any of the camera houses in town and you say
i am producing my first project which they have
all heard a million times ask for their time be
real limited hey can i borrow five minutes of
your time just have a couple quick questions
they'll probably be cool with it and then you say
i'd really like to know where the best producers
get production insurance who are independents
because studios are insured differently
so those people will say oh go to this place this
place or this place right they get the policies
from all the same places so for example in seattle
where we shot echo there's really only two places
to get film production insurance that's local
those are people that ensure huge commercials tv
series and big movies and then there's another one
which does small stuff we went with the big one
and we took our camera list so our camera
and optics list from kerner camera we took
our gear list from pgl and we sent them to the
insurance company because now they have an exact
document which is what we're insuring so we're
not [ __ ] around and they say okay it's this
much bang and then they ask you questions like
are you doing pyrotechnics are you doing stunts
are you doing underwater work are you doing um
anything that has a high vertical etc and that's
all producer things that they'll get used to when
they make more work but i would short answer is i
would call a camera house and just say what are
the top three and they'll tell you if they don't
tell you then they're being weird or you need to
just call somebody who's nice and then call them
and get the hard truth of how much
it really cost to make something
so what about uh production insurance for cast
and crew not just equipment sure what what's that
fall under uh well liability yeah yeah yeah so
basically you have an umbrella policy that covers
uh general liability general liability is anyone
who gets hurt or tries to sue you during a film's
production or afterward and then you have rental
insurance they call it inland marine etc etc and
then you have sort of specialty insurance which is
if you're doing big stunts or explosions or guns
or anything that involves something where there's
a risk to a person's life or if you're filming at
a location that could be dangerous you're filming
at a volcano you're filming on a train track
you know um and uh what i would do is just be
super honest about everything don't don't lie
don't steal a location you know don't don't say oh
yeah we're going to film in all these places but
we're not going to tell them about how we're going
to film in this aqueduct or in this like sewer
system or whatever because someone's going to fall
and and your career and i got a good education on
uh i got a good education on production insurance
for two reasons one i paid for my own production
insurance for my first film at 800 bucks and 800
bucks when you're 22 and have no job it's a lot of
money and they told me what it was for they said
it covers it covers the camera because with film
you're doing a fight movie it's only a three day
shoot but it's worth it totally was and then doing
a ton of ads after that you start to really
respect the comfort and safety of having a policy
that protects you and everybody else involved and
then from there you can have particular agreements
depending on a location or depending
on what is involved in the filming
you'll work with sag on that if it's for
actors you'll work with a union on that if
it's for your crew they may need to sign certain
documents that limits the liability of their
ability to go on a location because you say
i want twice as much protection i want this
policy and i want you to sign a liability
waiver that says you're willing to do this
so it's really uh it's an interesting job as
a producer because you're kind of a lawyer so
um but i would say research the hell out of it
it's not going to be sexy it's not sexy at all
it's boring it's like buying insurance for your
car but you will definitely definitely regret it
if you don't do it so we bought a year-long
policy because i knew that we were going to
shoot and then pick up in the same calendar year
and it saves people a lot of money to do that
but most people aren't that organized
so they should get sort of uh
they should get temporary production insurance
which is for a particular that's why they make
their money because if you say hey my shoe is
going to be five days and you shoot five days and
you don't get everything you don't have insurance
anymore so you call them back and you pay again
that's how they make all their money but if you're
insured as a production for a period of time you
can amortize it over over multiple shoots so um
but most people need to kind of get down the road
pretty far before that is applicable yeah that's
interesting though because you can save more money
it sounds like doing it that way than having to
just not have to react the policy and also like
you have a sense of like oh if anything goes
wrong and i gotta reshoot this in a week or
in three months it opens up as a producer it
opens up your schedule you're not trying to
shoot before your insurance ends right what
is making echo taught you about yourself
and filmmaking put yourself first then filmmaking
i think it was the longest project i've ever done
in my life so i mean definitely
um i don't look at schooling as a project
because it changes every quarter so to speak
it was this
competition that came out
in me with myself and it was
shattering a lot of naivete about how hard this
would be so you have to have some very challenging
internal conversations with yourself when you get
disheartened or when you feel alone in a process
even if you have a great support network it's very
easy to just shut off it there's there were rises
and falls of depression that were uncontrollable
because you just get so exhausted with the process
it taught me how to stop also
inside of my myopic obsessive nature
to finish or to get a moment perfect it taught
me to stop to enough is enough for a day like
if we're cutting we've been cutting for like 12
hours or something it's like stop take a break and
i didn't know that about myself you know um taught
me a lot about health and taking care of yourself
before the shoot during and afterward because
you can you can burn out before you start
shooting you can burn out pre-production
and then you get into production and you're
making the most important decisions about
performance or about coverage or about
a particular moment that matters and you don't
have the battery power to keep going and that
didn't really happen to me but i could feel
it a couple of times where i was like i am so
tired and i wasn't prepared for how tired my
brain was going to be and in the end of the day
i think it taught me that
no one gives you anything when
you get to the top of the mountain
like no one gives you a trophy or uh
like a reward or a bottle of champagne and formula
one race or whatnot you're you usually get to the
top of that mountain in the dark alone and you
have to figure out that that is what you want
it all you know i think at the beginning it
can be really romantic that when you finish
it's gonna you're gonna run through a ribbon in
a marathon or something but it's a lot closer
to what i've read about some mountaineering
expeditions or some summiting of some peaks
where a climber got somewhere in the dark alone
and no one was there and um you have to figure out
what got you there you know a lot of people on the
way giving you support a lot of people in the way
giving you nourishment a lot of people in the
way helping you know you didn't get there alone
but sometimes you do land there alone you finish
alone um and and then i think i also learned that
the affair is over you know i
think that before you make a movie
there's an affair it's like a
romanticized idea of the work and of um
every part of the process you know people
think editing is easy it's the opposite
you know people think that doing
sound mix is easy it's the opposite
people think they can kind of get away with
doing a di on like um you know their computer
i don't agree with that um and so what happened
also for me was learning that the love affair with
the idea of making a film was dead and for a
little while it wasn't replaced with anything
it was just over and that
didn't mean i wanted to stop
doing this it meant that there was an internal
feeling of emptiness and truth and at the end
of that there was a real strong light at the
tunnel and there was uh like a maybe a mature
maybe a stronger sensibility
of what this really takes to do
and so then when i looked at my next project
i looked at what needed to be fixed i looked
at how the script needed to be polished and
reworked i looked at the production schedule i
immediately pushed production off by a certain
amount i needed more time to do this right and
so i suddenly came at the sophomore film the next
film i suddenly came at that film with a sense of
um realism not optimism and um love and not lust
you know and um one of the things i also learned
was that i have a very um incredible wife you
know and our relationship went from you know
having lots of passion and having lots of
lust and just being so in love with each other
and then when we got married it became
complicated and super interesting
and better and richer and and the fabric of
everything became stronger and as very synonymous
with my breath my metaphor about the affair of
making a movie is over and it becomes better and
more interesting i don't think you can rush that
because i went through a lot of pain to go from
feeling the affair to being in love with this
craft more than i ever have but i had to go
through all of the darkness first and not pretend
like i had done it before i think some filmmakers
including myself years ago maybe had a sense of
feeling like i could do it and it wouldn't be hard
and it's a different journey so i
learned how to tell myself the truth more
yeah i don't remember the other question
wow i don't know if if it can top that i'm just
what did um making echo teach you about filmmaking
oh yeah sure sure uh what did echo what did
making echo teach me about filmmaking yeah
um it was a opportunity to
see strengths and weaknesses
under a microscope right these are
the things i thought i was good at
these are the things i think i needed to work on
and when you take the duration of your material
and when you take the audience's investment in
the material right okay so they were going to be
invested in a 30-second ad or 60-second ad or what
have you right okay so how much of that day is
it taking how much are they invested in watching
this content okay so that's what that is and then
over here it's like they're gonna buy a ticket to
your movie and give you two hours of their life
in a place that's not in their house and that is
a completely different invitation so it taught
me a lot about the reality of okay this muscle
this strength is solid this is good i can keep
improving that and i'm going to challenge myself
to do that on the next movie and here's how um and
then the the opposite's true which is i feel like
this aspect of the story or the script needed work
and it never got the right amount of work and [
__ ] it pisses me off but it didn't and it got
finished and it's done so it's like you can noodle
with it forever and you never ever finish it or
you finish it and you say i gotta really be honest
with myself about that's gotta get fixed next time
it taught me a lot about as a as a
director it taught me a lot about people
uh taught me a lot about um expectations
and morale i was reminded just before
this save my ass by the way i was reminded just
before we started filming like a week before
uh my dad says you're the captain of the ship
and i was like of course you know like thank
you and he goes i didn't mean it like that i
meant it like you're the captain of the ship
you are the captain of the ship things go right
you're the captain of the ship if things go wrong
you're the captain of the ship and after
four or five days um it became super clear
that i needed to adapt my leadership style to the
team not because they needed me to or asked me to
but because i was paying attention to being
the captain of the ship and whether that was to
um make sure to every day in the morning say
good morning to every person on the team and
at the end of the day tell every person on a team
great day which i did do and i had already really
been doing that but it wasn't hyper diligent it
wasn't as focused around you know what they're
working so hard every day and we're only 20 in
or 15 or whatever it was and okay great so that
i needed i needed to be a better leader and um and
then it also uh taught me a lot about editorial
i learned that i'm used to assembling and cutting
while i'm going on ads and we didn't have that
strategy on this film and we are changing it on
the next film so for example we shoot uh you know
we shoot material i look at some dailies but i
don't make editorial decisions the editor's not on
set working and then when we're done and we're in
the can i look at everything for a period of four
weeks or whatever and then we start assembling i
learned that that process was super inefficient
and the result of that process was that or the
reason why it happened was because we were working
so fast and so hard every day there wasn't time
to review material in earnest and so that's going
to change on the next film the next film we're
going to cut concurrently with the production
um i read a lot about how that's done i talked
to a bunch of editors in hollywood about how they
do it i followed the process or you know really
drilled in on the process the way they cut munich
spielberg's film they they cut it concurrently
and they were able to have a strong assembly
of the cat within i believe a few weeks after
production and it also creates an efficiency
in any pickups and etc so probably one of the
biggest lessons i learned was about editorial
and the last thing i really really learned about
was my passion for meticulous cinematography
and very specific color grade work in the di is
equal to my level of passion for sound design in
the mix you know i had had a lot of experience in
a di for commercials but the mix on commercials
is really quick they do it in a day it's done
you're not even usually there and on a film the
mix along with foley and design and dialogue
cleanup and looping and stuff you know this
takes months and months to do and i fell in love
with the sound design process i fell in love with
the final mix making this weighted ratio
decisions on the audience's experience
from a sound perspective and that was i've
never had that experience before so that was
really exciting so um yeah i'm sure my answer
to this question could be like two hours long
let's say we brought you in to address
a room of let's say 20 students
i don't know and they're about to make uh
their first feature they've already made a few
shorts sure what are you telling them what's your
advice to them um have they written their scripts
let's say half of them have half of them have
um okay i'll answer half of your question first
okay and then i'll ask you another question um for
the half that haven't written them yet i would say
write what you can shoot and shoot what you
can cut and cut what you can finish because
uh from my experience i started writing
ideas and then scripts that were um weren't in
the realm of possibility of making or producing
so i didn't waste time my approach was to write
material that i wanted to see and i wanted to make
and that's that's great if you're writing
scripts on spec but not if you're going to
write a script to make a film right which
you can shoot and so if you can shoot it
then you better be able to cut it so don't
don't try to shoot an action movie if you
can't cut an action movie because the last
part will be true which is you won't finish it
the only reason i have a career
is because i finished a film
first and then i became more and more and more
ambitious finishing things along the way and i
was talking to a friend of mine the other day
and he said 70 of all features are not finished
and so i think it's very hard when you
tell a film student or a fan of film
that hey man you know your kung fu action movie
is not going to happen right now you should do
a bank heist movie that ends in a diner and
don't show the heist or something like that
so it's a matter of shoot or write which you can
shoot and then finish it and make sure it's done
and then it will be a tool it will be a it
will be a calling card for you to move forward
um but nobody cares about your
career if you can't finish anything
second question or the second half of the
group i would say if their scripts are done
uh are they financed do they have
capital do they have investors
is the process they're in pre-production
or is the process they're in financing
okay let's suppose most of them will be either
getting money from family and friends putting
it on a credit card or they're going to some will
try their attempt at crowdfunding it doesn't mean
they will be successful yeah um if they're
at a stage where they're going to um
get film financing um i would sit down and have
a conversation with yourself or with your team
depending on how you how you're working if you're
working with a team of producers and you guys are
all a unit well then talk about it together if
you're not if you're just some rogue dude or a gal
and you're just gonna do this [ __ ]
like robert rodriguez uh then just have
this conversation with yourself and that
is what are you gonna do with the film
it has to have a purpose it has to have an
audience so you have to think okay i'm gonna
make this film and i'm gonna submit it to
sundance or i'm gonna make this film and i'm
gonna submit it to a horror film festival or
i'm gonna make this film and i'm gonna use it
to go get an advertising commercial director
job has to have a purpose because before
you can figure out how much an investment in
this project is worth it has to have a value
and the value has to be its goal right so its
goal is to i want it to festival and who knows
what will happen okay great well when you talk
to people about helping you that's your vision
your vision is i'm gonna tell you about two people
in a canoe in this horror movie it's like no no
they want to hear about what you're gonna do with
it when it's done they don't care about they don't
really care about how you're gonna make it they
really don't because they're not you also if you
know what you're going to do with it then you
can justify something like putting it on your
credit card which i would not advise to anyone
i know someone who did that years ago she went
into 60 000 of debt credit card wise the movie
went nowhere she was paying that off for 10 years
and she didn't have a goal with the film which
is one of her challenges and also it just sort of
it it became a pet project a vanity project
instead of a project she could really stand behind
if you're using someone else's money there's
also a sense of duty to finish so if you are
asking for family and friends and stuff like
that to help you if they do give you the money
there's a sense of debt which is good to them
crowdfunding i don't know anything about that
i don't know i have no idea how that really works
my guess is the only way you get crowdfunding is
if you have a flash teaser or flash trailer
or something that can tell a stranger that
their money should be in your pocket i know people
have done it before i've seen some teasers for it
you know success is probably
all over the map about it
but but yeah i would i would definitely say the
first thing is to figure out what they're going
to do with the film so that it legitimizes the
investment and doesn't become a vanity project
and then the last thing i would say to a
group full of filmmakers who's about to start
is communication is it can be really hard if it's
your art can be really hard if it's your work but
if you're working with the right people they're
all going to make your vision a reality don't be
a [ __ ] diva we've all met those people we've all
met the people who either went to usc film school
or they went to a filmmaking class on a weekend
and they are a diva no one wants to work for you
if you're a diva zero people want to work for you
and even less people want to work for you day two
so you have to figure out hey i'm in
pre-production hey i got some money hey i got
really good insurance and i have really good
people really good people and those are the
people that work super duper hard i know people
who are very successful who still work on no money
projects all the time if they like the people
and chances are that everyone i'm talking to
is in that boat so i would spend time getting to
know the people who are on your crew really well
you know i wouldn't put director on your [ __
] chair people put director on their chair and
it's like that's so stupid um years ago years
ago a woman i was dating her mother bought me a
director's chair and she was very wealthy person
and she had an embroidered it said director and
i have my name on it and i put it in storage and
now it's gone i never ever took it on a set ever
because one if you're a good director you're not
sitting in that chair ever and two nobody cares
the last thing i would tell people who want
to have a long future in the business is
find out what the people at your camera house and
your grip and electric house and your truck rental
house and maybe the people who do film permits
find out what they like to drink and buy it
i don't know how many bottles
of scotch or champagne or
cubes of beer i've bought for people who never
forgot that hey this is the guy who's always
grateful for my help right and um that's what
matters you know especially if you're underfunded
is that you really care about all the people
around you and all the people that get to decide
if you get to make your film so yeah and the one
last curveball would be somebody who wants to
make a feature they don't have any plans to do
anything with it they just want the experience
so and it's not really a vanity project in
that they're not totally casting themselves
they just want to know what it's like from start
to finish to make a film and what's the question
exactly question is what what are their set of
parameters how are they doing it differently
or is it all the same it doesn't
really matter i think that i have met
no one in my life who's wealthy enough
to make a movie by themselves for fun
and have no goal the only person i can
think of in history is like howard hughes
and so i i don't think i would be able to give
any advice to a person who had a trust fund and
thought it would be fun to make a film because
even if they have a lot of money and time
and they're creative and
even if they're super nice
they're still going to be engaging with
a lot of other people on their crew
they're going to be renting things in order to
make this experience possible and all of the um
all of the parameters around respect and all the
parameters around gratitude apply to them anyway
the only caution i would give
someone who's doing it for fun
is is probably easy for you to waste other
people's time and i learned i think it was
the first couple of weeks i was in la i learned
how long it took to get from one place to another
right and i was late to a couple meetings
i wasted a couple of people's time
and they made it super clear to never do that
again so i hope that this rich fictional phantom
person who's making a movie for fun pays people
a lot of money and doesn't waste their time yeah